I wonder if you think that a man can be
relatively happy or satisfied if his
wife or girlfriend is the one leading
the relationship do you think that's
ever possible I think guys will lie to
themselves and tell themselves that
they're happy if she's leading uh but
somewhere within them either a part of
them is dying or has died off um it's
not a good look you know you see these
relationships where um women lead and
these men follow um and they're these
weak soy beta males and she's you know
these uh powerful career-driven uh
multiple
degreed um leaders of the household or
they'll even call themselves Partners
you know that's a term that I hear that
that that pops up a lot when I have uh
conversations with women on my podcast
and they'll come on they'll say
something like my partner and I'll say
them who hold on a second what what do
you mean by partner are you guys
Partners in a law firm like how exactly
are you partners and equal in every
sense like help me understand that
um yeah so I think that women L
relationships uh they exist probably the
vast majority of them out there are
mostly women L you know that's why you
hear this uh atrocious sound bite happy
wife happy life you know it's like he'll
do anything to make her happy sort of
thing uh which really just you know over
time she slowly and surely loses respect
and uh desire for him it's really crazy
how how common it's insane how common
this is I just bumped to bumped into an
old neighbor from a couple years ago
really good guy and he kept talking
about for two or three minutes straight
how lucky he is which which is really
sweet and cute but his wife is just
looking at
him she was just like he's a good dude
you know but she was just she was like
yeah you better believe it you know you
did these guys are all over social media
on their birthdays and anniversaries
you'll see like a social media post like
on an anniversary you know for example I
love these cuz I think these are
hilarious you know see so it's a so it's
an anniversary and it's a post of his
wife and they're together with the
children around them or something like
that they're on a Sunset and it's a
beautiful poetic post about how she's uh
his everything and she completes him and
uh she's his best friend and you know
blah blah blah blah sort of thing and he
and she's tagged in the post right so
you click the tag on Facebook right and
and and his social media is a picture of
him with the family and the cover photo
exactly you're going with this you click
through and you go over to hers and
she's sitting on the beach with her
girlfriend's drinking wine saying
nothing about them on the anniversary
there's almost no picture of him on her
page whatsoever yeah or if she says
something it's it's it's very watered
down it's like 10% of what he puts out
there so that's always never a good sign
like that's like that's your typical
plugged in beta male today that uh you
know worships the ground that she walks
on and thinks that um that's what she
wants and women don't want that women
want to be with a giant women are
hypergamous they want to be able to look
up to you and if you're constantly
putting them the up on a a pedestal and
praising them um you know if you treat
her like a celebrity she's going to
treat you like a fan
right what I I agree what do you say to
women who listen are listening to this
and they say you think into this too
much this isn't reality you know things
just work themselves you know what I
mean because this is this is a very
detailed look on on female on male and
female psychology so what would you what
would you say to the women that are like
these guys are just so full of they're
so huh who hurt you right that's the
common thing usually yeah but no it's
it's a standard you know it's part for
the course uh it's usually some uh uh
you know disparaging statement about who
hurt you or you've got a small man uh
personality or you're bald or you know
something like that um it's very simple
um you take a look at them in their
lives right and then you ask yourself
would I want to trade my life for theirs
would I want to trade my relationship
for their relationship would I want to
trade my gal for her and for me the
answer is always no 100% of the time so
you have to understand that hate always
comes from beneath right uh people don't
ever get jealous of losers they're only
spewing hate because they don't have
anything they don't have a argument to
counter it right so all they do is they
have to adom attack you or they insult
you or they'll say you have a small PP
or somebody hurt you or something like
that but the truth of the matter is is
you're 100% right uh bombers only ever
get Flack when they're over the Target
and that's the reality of that
circumstance right so you just have to
you just have to laugh at it it's like
fine whatever you know it's funny though
because I mean I'm not my channel isn't
big yet and I do a lot of different
kinds of content this is definitely one
of the main topics a lot of the a lot of
the girls in my circles whether I you
know you know I'm I'm I'm a he so a lot
of the women in my circles tend to be
more conservative anyway I'm not going
to say there aren't
definitely much you know more feminist
leaning women but the ones that I
interact with typically tend to agree
with me on a lot of these things anyhow
yeah and I think they know that I'm not
going to change my way of thinking
regardless so they can disagree with me
all they want and I really couldn't care
less but I also I come at it from a
very I come at it from a very nurturing
point of view I want to be the leader I
want to be the provider I want to be the
one that that makes sure they're safe
physically emotionally spiritually this
is something want so for them to
disagree with all that to me it's just I
look at them kind of with a side eye and
I
go if if that's what you want if you
want what I do not
want I don't need anything to I I have
no reason to interact with you allog
together yeah and I never it really
never comes to that to be honest so yeah
you'll see these these uh you know
tradcons these uh you know traditional
you know conservative type of women that
will that will kind of give you the side
eye when you have these
conversations uh but when the bill comes
you're paying for it right if there's a
bang in the night and a intruder breaks
in the house you're taking care of it
not them um so it's just like one of
these uh problems with this toxic
version of feminism today is is it's
it's like an alak cart for them right
like true equality does not exist and
they're and they're constantly pushing
for what they call equality but they've
but they've had equality forever they
have more than equality if anything they
have Supremacy if you take a look at how
you know the family courts treat fathers
when you get divorced the advantage is
completely in the mother's favor always
in all Western countries a question um
you know so to say like you know the
things like ah you know I don't really
believe it or the side eye sort of thing
like that but you're out on a date and
you know you're paying the bill and
you're driving the car and you're
dropping her off and you're taking care
of her and all that sort of stuff it's
like you know like what's it going to be
you know things are too comfortable man
once we established air conditioning and
we have all of these roads highways it's
all Air conditioning's
fault and who created air conditioning
it's men so that means it's men's
fault that's just what it is when a
society gets too comfortable women
decide to step in then and and kind of
you know they take all the easy for the
most part nonheavy labor jobs that were
were put in place with because of men
and so sure it's very easy if you know
the if you've heard of the comedian
Andrew Schultz he jokes about this but
there's there's a lot of reality behind
it
yeah you know if if all of these if all
this infrastructure wasn't put in place
and built by men you wouldn't be able to
go and do the things you want to do turn
you know turn America back into the
Stone Age and see how how long these
ridiculous ideas last they won't
last so you know I I kind of just laugh
at it but I think history obviously
history repeats
itself you know any country that has
seen the highest points in society
eventually sees lower points and all of
these attempted implementations to
change what works always ends up showing
up meaning people end up realizing that
it was wasn't a very good idea to begin
with I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out